cinco casas en chernin hiv fueron
destruidas el 5 de marzo y un residente
murió cuando las fuerzas ucranianas
derribaron un bombardero ruso juliá red
nueva diputada local estaba en el sótano
de su refugio en ese momento con cuatro
niños
bajamos al sótano el 5 de marzo solo
para ordenar cambiar las sábanas y
sucedió sólo un par de minutos después
la casa comenzó a derrumbarse
más tarde vería la causa este sukoi 34
cuyos escombros aún están donde cayó
y estaba acostada encima de los niños
tenía miedo incluso de mover no era
imposible pararme porque el techo estaba
en llamas las fuerzas de defensa
territorial junto con mi esposo nos
sacaron de ahí bastante rápido
la supervivencia de yulia parece casi
milagrosa es muy consciente de que las
cosas podrían haber sido peores no por
tu sol a bordo de ese avión habían 5 más
de 500 kilogramos o 3 pero gracias a
dios no explotar
a dos cuadras de distancia se
desarrollaba otro drama los pilotos se
habían lanzado en paracaídas uno fue
asesinado el otro cayó en este patio
y
vimos el humo y que algo había caído mi
hermano decidió ir a ver qué pasaba
salió y vio que el piloto había
aterrizado aquí y corrió tras él
a mi hermano lo persiguió hasta aquí y
justo ahí en el gallinero lo mato el
pelo
en este momento los soldados ucranianos
también llegaron a perseguirlo
y
llegamos a este galpón buscándolo y
escuchamos gritos de no disparé me rindo
entonces le ordenamos que saliera abrió
la puerta y ordenamos que se bajara
iván quien hizo este vídeo dice que
protegieron al piloto de una multitud de
enojada
europol respondió como le habían
indicado que no sabía nada que estaba en
una misión de entrenamiento
gener el día anterior al derribo del
avión este edificio había sido
bombardeado los ataques aéreos sobre
charmin heat continuaron durante dos
semanas